Hello calculator fanciers
A bit of an unusual one today people have been sending in calculators for me to unbox. Which is very sweet of them
I think some people have calculators
They think should be unboxed by a professional
And it's very considerate of them to send them in so I'm going to go for the record of most calculators
Unboxed in a video sight unseen so let's get into it
First up one we've been sent in here at the South Surrey And Associated Regions Calculator Appreciation Society
for professionals and amateurs and no indication where or who has sent this in
So let's, I mean this is more of a calculator
I'm bagging so far, but I'm going to allow it well padded so it doesn't get damaged
It's come with a note please funny clothes free calculators
Which I hope you will unblock over the time for that and frankly
Three is cheating [of] somebody going [to] unbox one of these we're either going to do the scientific calculator with cover
We're going [to] do the home and office scientific calculator, or we will do the wilko
Scientific calculator make sure you get your sums right vote now
Yep, it's the wilko so let's get into that one let's pop this thing open using
scissors for when you're doing speed unboxing
I mean, you know I like my specialist tools
but sometimes you just need a multi-tool for everything and
We are in ok in no time for instructions in a speed unboxing is it a cover?
Yeah, okay. It is it all it's got a little stand. That's nice and
Let's fire it up. So we'll do a simple test to open all the way around it's a root 2
equals x Root 2
equals 2
It works [ok] you can see how someone saw the calculator and thought this this would be a good one to unboxed at this
What a drab little kit, there's very little going on here in this particular calculator
And so I don't think it wants any further tests
I'm impressed that someone had the enthusiasm to send it in but I mean
It's [just] it's not it's it's it's no gak co is what I'm trying to say [here]. [so] we'll pop that
In the not particularly exciting pile and move on to whatever this one is okay, and we have
All this is exciting it comes in a smaller
Unmarked box wow what could it be [I] mean, I'm not fluent in all
Barcodes so that I mean if you are fluent in but then barcodes spoiler alert, that's already given away
What's going to happen, but I don't know so it's okay
right [oh]
My goodness already, okay. It's not a rectangle. So I'm already more exposed than what [that] it's a keyboard, okay?
Well, let's test it first before we get too
Excited, how does it even turn? How's it turn on?
Is it solar-powered needs more luck nothing light, okay?
Where I can and it's on [alright]
So if we give it enough charge, [I] feel like we should do like the harmonic series. What are we going to do five?
times
six
Okay, it works okay, so it's a straightforward stuff with clear on okay on Doubles is clear
That's not very useful [off] is off on his
Con is on and doesn't play any sounds so if it played music as I was typing I'd be impressed
But sadly it doesn't they were
Keyboard calculator up next a oh hopefully labeled
This is the box that through useful think I've done enough unboxings to recognize a box when I see one
So let's get although use electrical tape which is [a] nice touch
Obviously professional circumstances, I wouldn't just be hacking at it with scissors and ripping it open but given
We're just doing you know a fun little unboxing of one of the amateurs have sent in with a letter
number file, I'm having to present
you the
staff
Device a device that looks and behaves like a normal digital clock if you hold down the middle button while turning it on so it
becomes a calculator oh
My goodness. Oh wow this looks this looks dangerous
It comes in bits. How on Earth did this not get flagged up by the post this would not look good on an x-Ray?
So okay, and that's all that we've got all the pieces
Seems to be the main body of it. This is a
Dangerously homemade-looking power supply. [I] don't
Wow, I mean it must be legitimate. They've written it on in tip x and the European
Socket very little something in the name of my organization which starts self sorry and associated regions which would indicate I'm doing this in England
And I'm unable to plug that in because we have Queens
voltage over here
Until [I] can't plug that into it is this European socket warranted work
I believe we had a vote on this recently so I'm going to file this away for further investigation up next okay
This one's comes Via Amazon. Let's cancel there
Okay, that was a very straightforward. This is almost a trivial unboxing. It's just open. Oh, okay. No, there's more [legal]
Still not fully worthy of an unboxing yet
and we have
well
Texas instruments
[okay], someone has sent us in a Texas instruments because on people get very upset that in America all their calculators
Come from Texas, and we don't tend to [have] [many] over here in South sorry, so an associate regents
So someone is finally cracked and sent me in a Ti the ti
30x [-] ass. That's an unnecessary level of versions. That's been through without a correct name so let's turn it on and
All it already comes with a calculation [preloaded] so it's already got two asterisks ^ asterisk times tan of something
[that's] to help people if you're using it, and you're not familiar with doing calculations as an example one or maybe in the factory
that's just that that's a
Texan testing it or actually if you rotate it. It's like a little smiley face. I appreciate all the feedback
Everyone gives however misguided it may be and I know everyone [wants] us to do More, Texas instruments
So we will do we've heard you you voted [with] your calculators. We will do a Texas
Calculator special, so I will get a whole bunch. We'll have a look at some don't worry. We will get around to Texas instruments
Thank you for sending it in
Okay, and this one. I mean
Unboxing it is trivial. We can already see it. This was actually it wasn't posted
Which is why it's already open this one someone came and gave it to me at the Manchester Science festival
So they wake up as it here is a calculator pen so let's get in there and have a closer look at it, and I
There are no surprises what we saw on the outside
it's exactly what we all look at the instructions there has to be a new record for the
compact and efficient placement of instructions and looking at no unnecessary information
I don't even use both sides there like that's all we need why print double-sided when you can just fold it in half
Afterwards and cram it in there
and they vary uk patent on they figured you know someone else is going to try and beat them to market, so the
crossover pen calculator market [it] says auto power off and
It's very efficient the moment. I turn it on it's off again
so
Is there no battery in that I mean if only there was some other way [to] use this without all there's not there's a pen
Right so obviously I can to the pen pen doesn't work the pen is also also auto off
What is this can we commit we should better get in there dude
Wow, so it's got ink in there. Maybe it's just been
Okay, so it was a [fair] [nick] [ever] gave this to me what I'm saying to question how much they really liked me
So I mean look at that. This is clear this isn't aged this is an aged product
[I]
don't know how
this went so long and people are able to resist opening it to get out the calculator pen this is clearly a product of a
Legal loophole somewhere, it's like you're not let a calculator
But you can bring in a pen or you have to do all your mathematical working out by pen and they've gone
Not a problem. [I] will do all [my] working out bike pen
right, so there you [I] [mean] full points for creativity, but
You have to take it into the shop and get it looked at properly because this is a vintage model
And it's [Gonna] need a proper
Refurbishment and a going-over before it's in a state for me to unbox and review it here
We go once at the world record. So next one up another anonymous Little Sack, I
Get into this
Oh my goodness second mystery box and so again if you know your barcodes
Them up your spoiler. [they're] all my goodness. It's
Transparent
Okay
Okay, that's kind of cool. Okay. It's a guard. It's a guide everyone. It's okay
I can remove that safely, [and] there's no way. That's gonna work. There's no way
I don't know what I'm pressing
Clear what oh my goodness often my desk is just dense with working out and notes about
Calculators and all sorts of math, and you go well what am I going to put my character?
I want to cover up some of [my] mouth now
You can put it down and you're not you're barely
losing any of the mass you had available before so I can get up quite handy, and I guess as a
professional
Unboxer if I've got another calculator. I want to unbox and I want to do some calculations at the same time
So I'm not under lee I can calculate I can unbox two at once like I'm barely
Obscuring the one behind it okay this one has already been opened
Because it wasn't labeled as the calculator on the outside and so I opened it thinking it was normal post
And oh my goodness, and this is it it was the casio Data [count]
100 and oh this is intriguing you can schedule a telephone call to tell someone a secret
I mean, it look like a particularly nice narrow thing
But should this situation ever occur you can do some calculations at the same time this because this is a new [generation] of calculators
So the box is already open that it is still here. I mean, it's missing missing a little tab there
Which is a bit, it's a bit sad, but it's got
The what on Earth?
Operation manual haven't got time for that in the speed unboxing
It's got is that a note is that [all] okay? It's the receipt from the original purchase
okay, that's quite nice, [so]
Someone has bought this cow you later in
December 8 so the 14th of December a year that ends in [8th]. I mean. I'm gonna guess
It's oh, there's a tap. [oh], thank goodness okay, so there's that missing turns from the end there, so this has been purchased
I assume in
1988 I could be wrong. This is why you should always use the full with the complete [timecode]
various appoint, let's not use that
someone's paid 17 pounds 75
P back in the day from this from John and that's actually I mean I know a lot of people
Try hard when they want to be a serious calculator collector
and they send them in I try and be encouraging and I always say keep all your
Documentation if you can't show the providence of the calculator
what is the point of having it in your collection and someone here is actually kept the
[original] sales receipt from a Branch of the John Lewis partnership so well done
Someone out there you're you're halfway to being a serious
calculator
Appreciator I mean I'm a little confused
Partly because this is a very new device and partly because I appeared of woken up in the year 2041
Which I mean, I had I mean time flies when you're unboxing calculators, but that is ridiculous
This is here because [in] some calculators if you press up up down down left right a bit
You know you can unlock special modes to the square root test
Times 2 Square root
equals
Eat nothing what times? Oh I didn't I it's probably before to
realistic buttons wow equals [Rf] is rounded down
That's not good, [so] I'm going to put that in my curiosity pile
think you've ever sent that in and I will have a closer look at one birth is going on there and
Maybe it maybe I can tease out its secrets who knows
And I'll keep the original tab can go in there with [a] receipt that I mean that is a pretty complete collection. I'm impressed and
finally in our attempt the eighth's calculator because you always do powers of two and
You sixteen I mean no no human could unlock sixteen taxes. Oh, haha
So some comedian out there. I mean, I don't really go into the jokes and
Comedy that someone thinks they're hysterical and they sent me in an abacus
[oh], I almost think I shouldn't even give it the the decent even unboxing, but I am professional and I refuse to
[let] down my
standards
Okay, [so] this sticks clear entry function isn't working properly some of the previous entry is still in there
yeah, that's a hard reset and
what is this someone's ah [there's] a
Manufacturing default and the display is there's like a dead pixel on the display of this abacus flip
note two dead pixels okay, so I guess I can turn into a
Calculation with this let's let enter in just this maybe that's seven
And I'm going to divide to [1/7] and then multiply by seven again
So there you are an abacus well done from up there thinks they're hilarious
And I guess I mean is it's quite a funny joke sending in an abacus
I can appreciate that that someone out there [is] a comedian but a
calculator unboxing video is no time for joking around so
It's just it's not appropriate [but] thank you to everyone who did send in proper serious calculators?
It's been fun doing a speed unboxing. We'll be back with [some] proper serious unboxing soon
This should be equal to the main tricky
What age group is behind that well clearly from the front children and amusement know hang on yeah?
It's a suitable only for Nobel prize with [anything] [that]
We want they're putting them all back in [altered]. So here it is there so we're going to be into the wall one hundreds